[Music]
when you're on the trail that long you
don't really think about how long is it
gonna take me to get to somewhere or how
fast am I going you're thinking about
don't get yourself hurt
my name is Karl Meltzer and I am an
ultra-marathoner we did 36 miles you
know it's pretty weekday but no one's
ever been this far in 10 days
I just recently broke the Appalachian
Trail record from Maine to Georgia at
2000 189 miles and I completed that in
45 days 22 hours and 38 minutes beating
the previous record by just a little
under 10 hours total mileage average per
day for that 46 days will be forty seven
point six the 80 is not a walk in the
park it's a hard trail every time I clip
my foot and it goes forward it totally
stresses going on I scream in pain you
really have to have a team it's not just
the one guy running it's really the crew
who if they're not perfect for you then
it really won't be successful I think
Appalachian Trail not only is it very
popular and iconic but it's also very
difficult now it's all downhill and easy
I am concentrating on my foot placement
all the time so 2 hours goes by like
nothing just because I'm zoned I'm
sowing doubt I slammed my head into the
ground a number of times and it beats
you down you have to expect that but you
can beat it too as long as you just keep
persevering and fighting through the
issues that you're going to have the
last day I ran 85 miles my body was so
amped and ready to be done that it
didn't matter really how far it was I
felt the same in my lady as I did a mile
10 my just numb at that point really
bonus it's important for people to know
that the 80 is a special place and it
should be protected it's a trail for one
who wants to gain fellowship with nature
no matter whether you're running it
whether you're walking it whether you're
taking 10 years to do it when you walk
that trail you have a vibe and you feel
it
every year someone else's gets a little
bit faster someone will break my record
for sure
it might come this year I don't know I'm
still going to be happy because I gave
it everything I had
you know I think that's what's important
I think lies is crazy but in a very good
way I think he's very smart I think he
knows what he's doing
people think he's a sadist or whatever
it's like my trail film a flair for the
dramatic I see man Laz Kentrell a true
backwoods rebel of Tennessee created one
of the world's most grueling foot races
one that is so challenging it leads many
to assume it must be an act of sadism
are you a sadist
no no I think people are obsessed with
comfort to the point that they forget if
you don't have any discomfort in your
life how do you know when you feel good
The Barking marathons is a 100-mile race
comprised of five 20-mile loops which
you have 60 hours to complete it's over
some pretty rugged terrain it's got a
massive amount of climb about sixty-six
thousand feet you have just your map and
compass it's cold it's wet it's
miserable you're alone the fact that
they'll probably almost certainly fail
makes it more appealing
they started in 85 and we've had 14
finishers yeah we always use a camel
because that's about the best cigarette
I think the course is located in frozen
head State Park home to the Brushy
Mountain State Penitentiary a location
not chosen by chance
in 1977 James Earl Ray the man who
killed Martin Luther King jr. made
headlines again when he escaped the
prison in the 54 hours he was free he
only made it eight miles from his cell
because this terrain is no joke Johnson
man you could put together a race course
that would really challenge people's
soul I think every runner would like to
do better than James Earl Ray and get
further than eight miles although some
of them don't everybody gets a big
number for each loop
there's paperback books which are kind
of strategically placed so that to get
them all you have to follow the course
and you pull out the page number that
matches your dip you have to turn your
pages to show that you've done the
course
he has a brilliant sense of humor he's
parodying the sport of ultramarathon
running those of us who run ultras we
have a certain egoism that we think
we're pretty good because of what we can
do and so he set out to puncture that
balloon
laz keeps making it harder because he's
trying to put it at the limit of human
possibility
[Music]
after they decided that they've had
enough and quit we play caps on the
bugle both because caps is what you play
for someone who's died in action and
because they they're being capped out
I think genuinely in his heart he wants
to see people succeed
when people actually finish five loops
and you see him at the end he's so
excited yeah if one or more of them
comes in it's an inspiring thing it's
hard to believe a human can accomplish
that
it's good that some years no one
finishes because the bark we should win
sometimes too when I'm running backwards
it almost feels like I'm flying because
it's such a different visual perspective
seeing how far I've gone as opposed to
how far I need to go when you're going
backwards you can really just take a
step back literally and enjoy what
you're doing hi I'm Erin Yoder I'm a
backwards runner I have the world record
for the fastest mile ran backwards my
fastest backwards mile time is 5 minutes
and 54 seconds
I've been running forward for over 20
years I started running competitively
when I was in elementary school and then
ran on scholarship during my early 20s
I ran so much that I sustained a knee
injury my doctor told me to stop running
and I really didn't want to stop so I
knew I had to make some sort of change a
[Music]
retro running or backwards running is
where you're literally just running in
Reverse and there's no impact on my knee
I run backwards everywhere I run
backwards on the treadmill I run
backwards on the track and also out on
country roads backwards running feels
great on my knee I don't feel anything
which is reason why I really enjoy it
[Music]
when I'm coaching my track team I
occasionally have them run backwards as
to enhance and diversify their training
workouts
onward and upward good job way to go
good warm up there there's more
backwards runners out there than one
would think
there are hundreds if not thousands of
people that decide to run in Reverse the
last World Championships there were over
20 countries represented in close to 200
athletes the backwards running has
allowed me to see things in a little bit
different perspective in a world where
everyone goes forward and I'm going
backwards it's really allowed me to just
get back to competing against myself and
not be so concerned what other people
are doing it found great gratification
in the fact that I'm just competing
against my own shadow
you
[Music]
people think fat people never get off
the couch and people think that fat
people sit around eating all day my
mission is to challenge people's
assumptions about fat people
I'm Myrna Valerio and I'm a runner I've
been running long distance for about
eight years I've done nine marathons and
ten ultra marathons with my longest
being 100k traditionally trail races and
other outdoor events have not always
been welcoming to people like me I'm
black I'm a woman and I'm fat when I go
to a race I know I'm breaking the mold
it's still very white and very male so I
know going in that I'm going to be
different
[Music]
ten years ago I lived a very stressful
life and so that took a huge toll on my
health I consult it with the doctor who
told me that I needed to change my
lifestyle pretty drastically if I wanted
to see my son I'll go up so I did I'd
had some experiences with people always
making the assumption that whatever I
was doing it was for weight loss after a
couple of years it was not a weight loss
thing anymore it's about fitness running
makes me feel like my most human self my
first mile was pretty awful it was
painful it was slow when I'm feeling
like this is really too difficult I know
that in the end I'm doing it for a
reason there's always a larger reason
the end goal not always only being to
finish but the more important thing is
that I'm out there because sometimes I
come in last it's amazing to me how many
messages I get on a daily basis saying
thank you for being you
thank you for living in your own space
and taking up space and not being afraid
to do that because that has allowed me
to do that I'm going to continue doing
it because I think people still need to
see me
[Music]
I'm not sick when I run like I'm really
I'm just so normal
you wouldn't think someone who goes
unconscious like 14 times a day runs
like you just wouldn't put it that way
[Music]
my name is Katie cook I'm 20 years old I
live in Dublin Ireland and I love
running I was dying
there's four two types of epilepsy on -
nine years old a one of which which is
frontal lobe epilepsy so at the moment I
have 14 seizures in the 24-hour period
they used to be 1617 so we're calm and
I'd lightly which is why I was getting
really bad dizziness from my medicine
through and into the hospital
they loaded me which is a term for
epileptics when you're going on like a
new medicine and I didn't wake up until
six days later I was a mobile for the
goths up two years I moved from being in
a wheelchair to being in the same her
frame when I gradually started getting
back into running it kinda gave me this
newfound energy I don't know why I put
on my ready boots and started running I
feel like it's so cliched but you kind
of feel like on top of the world that
you could do anything like I don't feel
sick anymore until I have a seizure I
don't like Damas you know it's amazing
feeling like all the endorphins like
pulsing or your body on it's great like
I like it's honestly like amazing I
train alone for most Myron's like during
the week however I do have a pal for my
races like official races which is dr.
Colin tardy
[Music]
so I have two roles so first of all I'm
her doctor the other role I play which
is to be her partner in running and my
job is to make sure that when katie has
a seizure if she's running that nobody
carts her off the course okay so before
I knew Katie she would run races and if
they were in public
people would you know quite reasonably
insists that she be carried off the
course which to her displeasure so my
job is to say no you know that I am her
doctor and that she's fine that she'll
recover and then she gets up and she
runs I don't let anything really get in
the way of living life at all I just
don't think it's the way to go I suppose
yeah I don't I don't let epilepsy get in
the way at all
[Music]
you